so this is about perfection and beyond
and what I'm going to do I'm going to
talk a little bit about the stronger
graph theorem and sort of tell you
roughly what was going on there and then
I'm going to switch to more recently you
know the stronger graph theorem was ten
years ago so then I'm going to switch to
more recent directions of research
that's that at least in my view have
been inspired or came from work and
interest in perfect graphs and so
different theorems he returns with
different people and Alva I'll say who
did what all right so this is graph
theory
it's about graphs graph graphs have
vertices and then the sum pairs of
vertices are adjacent and then we say
this pairs in age and some pairs of
vertices are knowledge isn't and we'll
say this pair is a knowledge and there
are two standard graph parameters that
people think about one is the chromatic
number so what's that it's when you want
to color the vertices in such a way that
if two versus two vertices are adjacent
then they don't get don't get the same
color right so somehow if you think of
your agencies representing conflicts
then you want to partition your vertex
sets into a bunch of conflict trees
conflict free sets all right well here
is a good way to do it to give
everywhere it's a different color
certainly you're safe no to vert sorry
Jason but somehow that's that's not
quite what I had in mind so the real
problem is
colors verts is so that the Jason
purchases get different colors and do it
with as few colors as possible and
that's called the chromatic number of
the graph and graph theorists and
computer sciences and optimization
people think about about this number a
lot so here's another another graph
parameter and that's the clique number
of a graph so what's that a clique is
it's just a bunch of vertices all
pairwise adjacent and then the clique
number is the biggest is the size of the
biggest clique you can find so all right
if you think about it for a minute
there's an obvious true statement here
the chromatic number is always at least
a clique number and because if I have
ten vertices all pairwise adjacent then
I need to give each of them a different
color so the chromatic number is at
least M now when you have an inequality
that came you know basically for free
what you ask is when there's equality
holds right there's something nice going
on there but just just to prove
inequality that's too simple so let's
try and think about it some more so when
is there equality when when is the
chromatic number and the clique and then
the clique number are the same when is
this obvious lower bound actually the
truth well so it turns out the answer is
pretty nice actually there are many nice
natural families of graphs where the
clique number in the chromatic number is
the same so let me tell you about a
couple of them so bipartite graphs you
know what that means you take two sets
of vertices each with no edges inside
and then you put some edges in between
and so then the chromatic number is 2
right color all this works is red and
all those works is blue and the clique
number is also 2
another thing you can do is take the
complement of a back to graph so that's
a little more complicated and
get back to that soon but let me just
tell you what it is so now instead of
taking two sets with no ages inside them
you take two clicks and then you put
some edges between them so it's a little
bit less obvious well actually it's a
theorem of kerning that those guys also
have the click number and the chromatic
number are the same so here's another
one comparability graph starts we'll
start with the partially ordered set set
and then make a graph where the vertices
are the elements of the set and two
vertices are adjacent if they're
comparable in your partially ordered set
so again this is they're sort of known
theorems and in mathematics that that
for this graph the clique number in the
chromatic number are the same so so far
so good like this sounds like a good
question we are getting many nice
interesting interesting families where
where it's true unfortunately you can
also cheat you can take this example
which is my favorite graph one at most
night-night perches which I'm not
telling you what it is and then I
click with 100 purchases and I take this
joint union meaning there are no edges
between them so what's the story with
the graph well the clique number is a
hundred right there's a clique of size
100 sitting here on the right I can
certainly color it with a hundred colors
right - I can color every vertex here is
a different color making heller
every vertex here is a different color
and there are no edges between them
but somehow this didn't really tell me
anything about the interesting part of
the graph right you still don't know
what my favorite graph of 99 vertices is
so what that tells you is that this is
not quite the right question it's it's a
question in the right direction
when our Chi and Omega the same but
somehow it doesn't exactly capture kind
of the interesting part of the world
because you can construct examples where
the answer is yes and yet the example is
maybe not very interesting so ok so we
want a better question we want a
question where you know the nice hunter
answers are still there the nice
families of graphs still have the
property we're asking for but but you
can't let say you can't cheat you can
you can sort of construct an example
which is not actually an interesting one
and so that's so Claude bear asked this
question in the 1960s
so he started talking about something
called perfect graphs so graph is
perfect if the chromatic number in the
clique number are the same but I require
more or he requires more I also want
that if I delete some vertices from the
graph and I look at what's left
still the clique number in the chromatic
number are the same so to say it's more
more precise in a more standard language
I wonder the clique number in the
chromatic number are the same for all
induced subgraphs so let me tell you
what an induced sub graph is so a little
graph is an induced sub graph of a big
graph if I can get the little graph from
the big graph by deleting some vertices
and then if I deleted the vertex right I
have to delete the H is attached it lost
the net but I'm not allowed to delete
any other edges so the only way to get
to the waitress is by deleting one of
their ends and there's an example here
so let me start with this guy well this
is an induced sub graph of that because
to get this from that all I need to do
is delete this or X this is not an
induced sub graph of that well the
easiest way to see it is they have the
same number of vertices but different
number of edges so that means whatever
changes I made were not by deleting
vertices and ages I had to delete all
right so again so for a graph to be
perfect for graph to be perfect means
the clique number and the chromatic
number are the same photograph and also
for all induced subgraphs
all right so before I before I go to the
next slide so it turned out to be a
really good definition I mean for a
number of reasons one is that you know
they the nice examples we had before
still have the property you know the bad
thing about it are the bipartite graph
if you delete some verses from it yet
another but effective so so the property
is preserved no comparability graph you
delete some verses from which you get a
comparability graph for a smaller part
so again here maybe the clique number in
the chromatic number is the same and
maybe they're not so so the example I
wanted to get to you know if I managed
to get to you know so how do you know
you came up with a good definition well
if one one good thing that happens is if
it has surprisingly nice properties in
areas where he didn't define it that way
right so being perfect was defined to do
something nice with respect to this
notion of color but then it turned out
that actually graphs are the perfect
health
other interesting properties for example
there are problems that are and the
completed general but you can solve them
important polynomial time on perfect
graphs so you can find the size of the
biggest clique it simply complete for a
general graph but you can do it in
polynomial time for graphic that's
optimal coloring and be complete for
general graphs you can do it you can do
it involve a no time to graphic up so I
will come back and talk about it some
more later
also there are you know you can source
you can state the property of being
perfect in terms of certain properties
of some polytopes you know solutions
there certainly in a program and again
turns out this linear programs behave
well you know when they come from from
from perfect ups so somehow turned out
to be a very good definition because
encompasses a lot of different things
people people have been thinking about
talk about it some more so we've seen or
we've seen some photographs now let's
think about some graphs that are not so
here's one so let's take so it's called
an odd cycle so what you do is you put
an odd number of vertices on a circle
and now you make consecutive ones
adjacent and not consecutive ones
knowledge ease so what the clique number
well the clique number is took the only
Jason's the only sets of vertices all
pairwise adjacent they're consecutive
prints well the number well I claim it's
not true because suppose I could color
this with two colors well how would I go
about it they'd have to go 1 2 1 2 1 2
and next step so the chromatic number is
in check check all right so this cycles
and cycles of 2 n plus 1 courses are no
perfect in fact Chi is different from
okay so I'm if you're not if you really
display and possibly listening to me
then you notice that I haven't said
everything that's on the transparency so
I have to take an odd cycle of legs at
least five in order for it not to be
perfect
red because why the water fell over the
cycle of legacy it's true that they need
three colors to color it but on that
hand it's not true that the clique
number is two number three so let's do
another one
this is called the Continental an odd
cycle let me tell you what this is
again I put 2 n plus 1 vertices in the
circle and now I make consecutive pairs
non-adjacent and all other pairs
adjacent right so what I did was we
release into the exactly the opposite
from what they were in the top picture
no well I cannot a clique and no contain
two consecutive vertices right because
the sector fails the knowledge isn't so
if I'm trying to construct the click the
best I can do is go yes no yes no yes no
no so if I have 2 k plus 1 riches the
best thing I can find it's nice kick
what about the chromatic number
well how many torches can be colored
with the same color at most 2 right
because the only non adjacent Center are
consecutive pairs if I have to keep us
one person I'm trying to color them and
each color can only contain 2 while I
need 2 k plus 1 colors and in fact you
can do it in here as well
kay Kyser plus one again not perfect and
again I have to do links at least five
because for for an authentic cycle of
length three well it's true that the
clique number is 1 but the chromatic
number is also on all right so this were
no imperfect like two inches in terms of
classes that are not perfect and they
have two important elements perhaps in
the North that see why so when they're
she came up with his notion perfect last
he made two conjectures about them while
I was what's called the weak perfect
graph conjecture and what what it says
is that the graph is perfect if and only
if it's complement is perfect no need to
tell you what it means to take
compliments maybe you've already figured
it out so I started the graph and it's
complement is a graph where they trace
is a precise precise reverse so same
very upset and two birds are adjacent in
the complement if and only if they're
non adjacent in the graphics elements
now if you don't redo and if you just
think about the first one here
and it's kind of an amazing statement
right over the we define the special
drugs to be something to do is coloring
and suddenly it says well actually it's
complement in their coloring is you know
not at all confident in there now if you
do read on then suddenly it's all
becomes clear secondly capture him in if
the is what's called a strong portion of
conjecture and basically what this what
that says is that the two families of
graphs that we saw on the previous line
are the only minimal graphs that are not
perfect right so if i telegraphed if i
take a big graph and i find the little
sub graph in a little induced sub graph
in it it's not perfect
well then the big rap wasn't perfect at
right being perfect means something for
all thank you suburbs so if i take a big
graph and it contains one of these old
where else well it's not perfect what
gravity says that this is it the only
way to make graphics not perfect this by
forcing it to contain an odd cycle or
the complement of not cycle conjecture
everything is obviously complement and
their two families I'm forbidding are
precise the complements of each other so
if you believe the second objection
you should believe the first conjecture
but that's not how the proofs were found
so the first the first conjecture became
etherium in the early seventies it's due
to all of us and basically what he did
he was thinking about it from the point
of view of optimization and and politics
and then is actually beautiful
we prefer graph conjecture of the weak
perfect graph theorem there's actually
beautiful two-page proved you took
aspirin it's you know it can teach it in
the lecture to to the course of
undergraduates it's kind of chicks with
matrices and you don't understand
anything at all but it does it's a
beautiful so that's
the stronger gave to him took a little
bit longer and that's that series out
with neil Robertson ball Simran Robyn
Thomas in 2002 but it's a hundred fifty
page paper so it took a while for it to
get your three-day publish so 2006 is
the weekend it oh so what I want to do
now is talk a little bit about some
ideas in the proof of strong perfect
after all right so what do I need to
prove in order to prove the strong
traffic that's it
I need to prove that graph is perfect if
and only if no induced sub graph is an
odd cycle of the component of an outside
so that means I'll be thinking a lot
about grass but annoying you sub graph
phrase and outside the content of in you
or not cycle so the key with me and this
is called edge case that's not named you
to bear its name due to bash your father
mm that diversion perfect position and
one direction is clear it if something
is perfect then it cannot contain
anything with click numbering to
myhumber difference so must be better
the difficulty
there implies perfect and so the idea of
the proof sorrows
I believe was crawling in the field that
probably what we need to do is take a
step back and forget about the shopper
for a conjecture for a minute and just
think about barriers and just try and
understand bears grass and prove a
theorem that would describe their
structure and then hopefully you know if
we really understand their structures
and whatever question you have about
them and you can answer it if you really
describe the structure of a certain
class class of graphs completely
did you inclusion are they perfect well
let's go and check so that didn't quite
work out that way but that's much of
effort was directed in that dish so that
people agree that somebody came up with
the idea that many people can happen the
idea that we need to prove a triple
theorems like this let me tell you about
the students other students here they're
not theorems they're sort of method
tables they're many triples of
statements that that would fall into
this pattern so the first theorem is
every paragraph is either basic or
admits a useful decomposition the second
theorem is every basic graph is perfect
the third theorem is a minimal counter
example is for a graph conjecture and it
does not admit a useful decomposition so
suppose I could prove a triple theorems
like this now why have a why how I want
let's just go
so suppose the strong traffic graph
theorem is false then there is a
paragraph that's not perfect and let's
look at a small stone so and that he did
with the first term well either it's
basic ordered meets useful decomposition
if it's basic then I kill them to it's
perfect contradiction if it admits
useful decomposition we're gonna come
contradictions of theorem 3 because
theory says many more examples the
conjecture don't admit in useful T
composition so any people like this that
you could prove would get you to worry
about and in fact that's what happens we
so with Neil Roberts and Paul simmer and
Robin Thomas we prove the triple
theorems like this let me tell you let
me tell you what they were so what I
need to tell I need to tell you right
basically I need to fill in contact
content into theorem 1
I need to tell you what basic graphs are
and then I need to tell you what useful
the compositions
and then from my definitions theorems
two and three hold or isn't good
so basically well some of them you've
already seen we have factor graphs we
have complemented by the digress I'll
show you the definition of the
complement of a graph again so yes right
so the complement of G has the same
vertex set of G and two vertices are
adjacent and the complement if and only
if their normal Jason to G now the next
one is like this so what does it mean
well that basically the intersection
graph of edges so the library and
services that appear to say liner L of
tree nothing of U of Q so the vertices
of L of G at the edges of G and then two
vertices are adjacent in the
corresponding to H is sharing it
that's so basically you build a graph
that reports which pairs of edges of the
original graph meet and we stopped
all right so like that laughs about a
gas not getting worse
compliments of line graphs of back to
graphs so take about a graph take its
complement take a bath take that they
could slang that take
that's the fourth class we need and then
the fifth started something called
double stream graphs and that need not
tell
that's really matter now this point
somebody often asks so this is your
probably something complimentary and you
have to have an odd number of basic
classes that's true correct
well because for every class you should
also contain its complement what you're
proving is continent invariant the
continent of a doublespeak graph is a
double speaker all right
so these are the basic classes
so now let me tell you about the
compositions and again it's not really
crucial what they actually I'll just
I'll just go through it quickly so the
first accommodation is called excutive
and what that means is that you can
partition your graph into poor non-empty
parts your partition the birds into four
non empty parts a b c LP and then
everybody in a education to everybody
it'll be nobody in c is equation to
anybody in t and the other edges i don't
care let's so if I delete a union B then
the graph becomes disconnected because
there are no edges from C to D if I
delete C Union D the graph becomes
disconnected in the complement right
because everybody in the education to
everybody and B to say that's saying and
the complement nobody so alright so
that's that's a good thing that's a
compliment invariants natural in the
world of perfect graphs we like this
kind of decomposition so the truth is
that we don't but but for now we don't
know
so we'll get back to that and then the
other composition is called Chu Chu and
what that means again you can partition
the graph into two parts were sort of
the communication between the two parts
is in some system in there what does
that mean I can partition my graph and
the vertices of the graph into top and
bottom and then in the top there are two
special set for day 1 and V 1 and the
bottom there are two special sets called
a 2 and V 2
everybody here is adjacent to everybody
there everybody here is adjacent to
everybody there and there are no more
edges from talked about so doesn't
exactly matter what it is but the point
is that I can you know partition the
vertex set into top and bottom and the
communication channels between Tom top
and bottom don't work two things you can
do
alright so now scoo partitions are
complement in the end two joints are not
complement in there for a graphic
attitude journal for its complement to
have a to journalist or two completely
different things so again I'm proving
something
and so I will also need confluence of
two tricks all right so here's what
approach right this is team one
so if you give me a bit craft then
either it's bipartite or complement
bipartite or
Landgraf a bipartite or complement of
line graph of Viper tights or a double
split graph these are my basic classes
or it admits something called the
balanced queue partition that's the
technical details of skip over it
balanced cue partition or to join or the
complement of needs to check the last
outcome was not coming
another the composition racially
headbutt button there
you don't dwell on it
alright so that's that's that's too much
that the team's it tells you something
about the structure of every basket and
it takes 155 pictures to prove so
alright and then like I said so there
are times two and three that goes all be
perfect and these are mostly terms of
Koenig except for double spring drafts
that we invented because otherwise the
proof fell down and we have to prove
separately and then for the compositions
so tutorials were known to be to be
useful to composition that's it they're
due to the corny Jason Cunningham and
then that was Cupertino it's not very
hard to to prove the taro swings anyway
tell me let's talk a little bit about
the proof so when you turn to prove it
in with eight outcomes the trouble is
you don't know which way to push right
so here you have a graph and you're
trying to prove that this graph has some
property but
you don't know you what you need to do
with the
Oh Jason at least aversive knowledge
because maybe in outcome one there
Jason's and not come to their knowledge
ease so what you need is suddenly to
break in world into different parts were
not quite so many options are present in
each part right and then that space
today
the proof is sequence of steps where at
each step we assume that something is
present in the graph and there's
something directs the behavior of the
graph this allows some of the outcomes
and another hand we can use it as sort
of an anchor we can look at the thing
that we assumed is present and then see
how they are sort of graph attaches to
it and then did use what we need about
the behavior so that's obviously very
very so I thought I would show you one
step that I can actually just explain
the tear so so here's here's an extra
it's a graph on on eight vertices and
disregard the colors of the of the
vertices for now so in
is that it does not fall into any of the
basic classes it's not about the graph
because it has a triangle it's not the
component of a back type graph because
it has a table sort of size 3 it's not a
line graph because it has what's called
the claw it's a vertex with three
pairwise non-adjacent neighbors and it's
not difficult to see that those can't
occur in line graphs it's not the
complement of a line graph because it
has a triangle in the products with no
labor in this triangle which is the
complement of the call and you can also
check it's not so that was picked so if
I look at a big batch graph and it
contains one of those I know that my big
batch graph is no big right so I've
ruled out five out of my my eight hours
I'm doing well so the next step so so
far it was intelligence the next step is
luck in fact it turns out that only one
outcome is needed when you continue so
now don't disregard the colors of the
vertices and then you can see
you graph it made the skew partition
because green is adjacent to it
and there are no edges from P George
that's exactly what it means
Jordan a the skew partition and don't
know that actually this competition
persists in the hole so it's not the
only one satellites
it's your ABC so Green is a red SB
Pinkus see in orange St so and turns out
you can define rules for that for the
remaining vertices of the graph that's
to which that they should go into and
prove that the skew partition persists
all right so that's that's nice that's
if you contain that you only have one
outcome I mean usually doesn't work
quite as well but but but this is this
is a this is how the steps
all right so and just remind you what we
are doing right so we were proving to
him one that says every brush graph is
that a basic coordinate to use for the
composition with the hope that there are
companion theorems two and three to go
with it that say every birth death is
basic and every every you know and the
useful decomposition cannot occur in a
minimal country so all right so like I
said the serum that I showed you was
eight outcomes that was 150 pages that
was hard now you know maybe there is
something easier you can prove if you
allow other decompositions another and
not the basic process and the answer is
yes it's true so probably about 2010
full simmer and I proved now that
another triple of theorems like this so
we change to 1 and then we proved teams
two and three to go
what we did there one waited two more
decompositions the first decomposition
of something called
so an even paragraph means two purposes
so that every induced induced path
between them has an even number of edges
and you can see that the smallest
country examples your best conjecture
cannot continue and that was you know
the compositions that people had talked
about a lot it just didn't make it to
the first cut of the theory is that in
the composition is something we call the
dominant pair and that's really matter
but it's to non adjacent vertices that
don't need the whole graph so if you
instead of having a thousand you have
ten outcomes allowing in addition these
two decompositions group the outcomes
differently so it looks like like
they're separate but I did it the old
way they would attack and so now the
proof is only hundred pages longer but
you might not be so impressed but so the
proof goes and a kind of normal
intuitive way so this is present
mrs. president and you proved something
and then there's a really hard bit sort
of we you know it seems to work but we
don't exactly have the intuition for why
it works and what this allowed us to do
is cut out that paper but that was
intuitive a bit that we didn't like so
they mention the proof went out by 30 by
30 percent but I think the complexity of
the proof went down
all right so that's that's that all
right so I mean it would be nice to get
my real simple proof of this job like a
graph theory I'm not kind of one where
you go down 200 pages and you're happy
but that hasn't happened yet
so instead let me tell you about some
other some other problems about buffer
girls one was to test if a graph is
perfect right so as I said earlier one
nice thing about special graphs is that
there are certain problems that are
np-complete in general but you can do
them and follow me on several projects
well if that's you know is that they're
selling point then
NASA to give me a grant that they could
test whether it's perfect or not and
it's perfect I'm gonna go and apply this
clever algorithms it's not perfect so
I'm gonna say sorry there's nothing I
can do that will open until after this
term perfect I've been doing this job
but we have to get you a spoon but now
it's no so smooth you [ __ ] much
coverage and so what we do is we we test
this if a graph is back and we test with
a graph contains an odd cycle of content
of non cycle which now by the strong
perfect after we know it's the same as
testing whether it's perfect and that's
the only sort of connection to the
stroke traffic accident you would think
you know something like theorem 1 which
tells you what all births are like would
help with designing an algorithm to test
for better but it didn't so all right
rather you said above this the
complexities and to the ninth which you
know it's not great but to our credit
there are two bottlenecks two places an
algorithm where we have a step that
takes time n to the ninth so so I'm just
gonna improve what they have to improve
it twice alright so here's another one
and now I mean I seem to contradict what
I said but but I don't so if you give me
a paragraph find an optimal coloring now
you can do it's using techniques from
commenters optimization the ellipsoid
method all sorts of complicated stuff
but you know it's a problem in graph
theory so how about the combinatorial
you know graph theoretical algorithm
that says color these products delete
that's not X no get the neighborhood of
a the verdicts and find a find a
colouring that way and that's open
that's possibly the biggest open form
left in the in the field of perfectly
so what say I tell you I give you a
graph I give you a third season HS I
give you a vertices and the Chasen pairs
and I also tell you it's perfect yeah
yeah I mean or you can run the algorithm
to test if it's perfect and stop
I'll also be happy with it in with an
algorithm that colors a perfect graph
and stops if the graph is not perfect
all right so so a possible thing I could
try and do is again use use a
decomposition theorem right so I mean
there are many algorithms in graph
theory that work like this you want to
do something to some class of graphs so
first you learn how to do it on the kind
of easy examples in the class and then
you say well here the general
representative of the graph is built
from VZ from the easy representatives by
somehow gluing them together and then
you extend your coloring along your
gluing and you know theorem one seems to
seems to be served in that direction
right the basic classes we know how to
color and there are some decompositions
but doesn't work we don't know how to do
it and the problematic decomposition is
that skew partition decomposition that
you know seems so nice and natural at
the start if all your head were to joins
then you would know how to do it but
because of skew partitions we're stuck
and in fact so
if I started with the graphs that
there's no submit rescue petition and
again it says here balance skew
partition let's ignore that it's a
technical thing so if I start with the
glass it doesn't meet the balance queue
partition then I can comment or really
color it sits on your fill trunk and
Christina Bush courage so not talk about
the proof of that but the skew partition
is really a problem it seems it may be
kind of our best hope if you wanted to
follow the truth is to prove to everyone
that doesn't use skew partitions right I
mean we could write think harder and see
what to do with your partitions but that
seems too hard you know we tried so it
seems that really if an approach like
that it's a decomposition kind of
approach we're going to work what you
should do is go further back prove a
different version of tm1 that doesn't
use skew partitions and then go from
there
and Robin Thomas has a conjecture of
what that's good theory one might be but
all right so let me let me switch gears
and talk about other things so perfect
graphs have the property that the clique
number and the chromatic number and say
what if I weren't quite so greedy what
if I wanted
graphs were the chromatic number is
bounded in terms of the clique number
well that's that's a reasonable concept
to study and that's something called Chi
bout Chi boundedness so let's look at a
class of graphs that's closed and
they're taking induced subgraphs that's
just for convenience and I'm going to
say this class is Chi bounded if the
chromatic number is at most a function
of the clique number all right so okay
maybe it's a trivial property maybe it's
always true and the answer is no so if I
look at the class of all graphs then
it's not true that the click the
chromatic number is bounded by a
function of the clique number in fact
there are graphs with no triangles
clique number two and and I retire there
are large chromatic numbers and there
are many constructions the moshevsky
graph is my favorite one but I think I'm
going to skip it because it's not that
important all right so so the class of
all graphs is not a bounded and you can
ask well what classes are quite bounded
now when we work in perfect graph
somehow induced subgraphs seems this
nice and hopeful direction right we from
refer be the certain family of induced
subgraphs and a beautiful property
emerges so you know maybe it's some
other things are some other nice things
are going on with induced subgraphs
maybe induced subgraphs are like miners
for those of you who know but what
desire you exclude one and suddenly you
know the role becomes clear and simple
well that doesn't seem to be the case at
least not start in this context because
so you might think
think that for any fixed graph if I look
at graphs that don't contain it as
induced subgraph then this class is
compounded and the answer is no because
for be a triangle right and we already
said they're like not containing a
triangles an induced sub graph is the
same as not containing a triangle in any
way and so and we already said there are
triangles free classes are arbitrarily
large chromatic numbers so that doesn't
work okay and in fact the situation is
even worse because there's a team of
mergers that says there are graphs with
arbitrary arbitrarily large girth an
arbitrarily large chromatic number so
girth means the length of the shortest
cycle so for every K and every G their
graphs was chromatic number at least K
and girth at least G what that tells you
is that if I take any graph with a cycle
and I look at graphs that don't contain
it as an induced sub graph I'm not going
to get a chi bounded class right because
their graphs later I forbid this graph
on 15 vertices but their graphs of of
girls at least 16 with I retire a large
chromatic numbers and they won't contain
my graph because my graph contains a
cycle
so if you were going to get a graph you
know to get some class which is defined
by forbidding an induced sub graph that
would be counted the only chance you
have is to forbid a forest right so if
for Grove H is Chi bounded then H is the
forest and that conjectured to be true
Etha conjecture of G are fresh and it
was also independently conjectured by
Sumner that for every forest if you
forbid is an induced sub graph then what
you get is a chi bounded class and
that's actually you know so the storm
graphic graph theorem was like I said
almost ten years ago this is now this is
something that people are working hard
on now and you know no tell you about
what I know about it but because it can
be really summarized in five minutes but
all right
and so note
if you just wanted this conjecture then
not very much is no right if you just
wanted to know for which forests for
being it gives you a carbon it does then
not very much is known so Jeffers
himself proved it for a pass and then
here stood and Penton rise proved it for
trees of small radius radius at most two
and then Alex Court has a topological
version where instead of excluding
one tree he excludes a fixed tree and
all its subdivisions and then he can
prove that the class you get the sky
bounded but the recently there have been
sort of other approaches to this
conjecture that maybe maybe we read some
would lean somewhere but let me not
alright last thing
so okay so Jennifer says if I forbidden
your subgraph then the class I get asked
I bounded what if I weren't quite so
greedy right so what does it mean to be
kybounder
that means either there's a huge clique
or I can partition the vertices into not
too many color classes meaning into not
too many independent sets
well what if all I wanted was either a
huge clique or one huge table set
hey that's sort of in some sense weaker
than gr fish and that's conjectured to
be true for classes of graphs that are
defined by forbidding and induced
subgraph that's their shadow conjecture
so what it says is for every graph H if
I look at graphs that don't contain age
as an induced sub graph then either did
a huge clique or there's a huge
independent set and huge basically means
much bigger than than in the random
graph so huge means polynomial in the
number of vertices of the big graph is
logarithmic in the number of vertices
so alright so this is just a more or
less a formulation of that so let me say
a small graph has their the channel
property if H has their different
properties there is some Delta of H so
that every grafts that doesn't contain
age has a click or stable set of size
the number of vertices to the power
Delta H and then the conjecture is every
graph has the additional property right
this is just kind of really easy you
know in a convenient term to use it's
not not any new information their
channel conjecture says every graph has
their - ina property now we're not doing
very well with this conjecture either
it's only it's only known for a few
graphs let me just say so again what's
let me sort of explain the complete
connection with Chad fresh a little bit
better so if I had a class of graphs
that's Chi bounded by a polynomial
function right so if for some H I could
prove that the class of graphs that
don't contain H is an induced sub graph
is Chi bounded by polynomial function
that would mean that H has their child
property and there's a calculation here
but let me let me know Choi - well like
I said not very much is known so it's
known for grabs on phosphor vertices are
known to have their channel property the
bow which is
this graph is known to have very sharing
property where to deal with moody Safra
and there is a beautiful streak of a
long pattern show emotion that allows
you to build infinitely many graphs with
the additional property
so what you do is substitutions you take
two graphs that have the property and
now you substitute one for the verdicts
of the other and that gives you another
clip another class with the property and
you can do it over and over and over
again okay so the so now you know before
there - all cases of channel were
interested now interesting now only
proving proving that graphs that are not
obtained from smaller graphs by
substitution have the additional
property is interesting but you know how
to show you where we stand so this is
some open cases
right so for each of these guys they
forage pass this is the component of the
forage pass this is a cycle length five
we don't know how to prove that they
have their channel property so you know
the roads the roads wide open
and then we just finish with with
another twist on there - I know
conjecture which somehow seems to work
better it's so say say what it is what
precisely in it but it's something else
also proposed by our designer by a long
par contre motion and it's a girl into
there - I'll conjecture but somehow you
can get further you know you don't get
stuck at a 5 vertex crap so I don't know
what that means given that this
equivalent but but I thought I would
tell you so a tournament is is a
complete graph with reactions and edges
now the original conjecture says if I
forbid an induced sub graph then there's
a huge click or a huge table set the the
Elan Parker Marshall conjecture says if
I for every little tournament so for
every tournament if I look at a big
tournament that doesn't contain this
little tournament just in the sub
tournament then the big tournament has
something called a transitive sub to
comment which is very big and transitive
just means you can order the vertices
from left to right and all the way just
go from left to right which is the same
as saying no directed triangle at so
instead of looking for a big click or a
big stable said I'm looking for a for
this other creature called transitive
subtly and again it has the same
properties that in the random
tournaments transitive subdomains have
size local number of vertices and they
conjecture the with anything excluded
suddenly it becomes polynomial in the
number of vertices
and so there somehow we like I said the
situation is better so today with any
burger and Christophe caramels key that
there is an infinite class of prime
tournaments with their - I know property
let's again having - a private property
means the same thing if I excluded that
guarantee is big big transitive stop -
limits and so the big and again the
trick of substitutions works so we're
only interested in prime tournaments the
biggest prime graph we know where there
is Shallon property is the bull has five
vertices for tournaments for some reason
there are prime tournaments there are
infinitely many prime tournaments with
their child property and this is a
better way to think about the additional
conjecture and let me stop here thank
you
to the characterizations in terms of
linear or semi definite
who is also conjectured a
Daboo question right I haven't really
thought about that but but actually
comparability graphs citizen
every crab spent the day in the nuts
under roll here a basic class or
anything
is it as gift some sense why they seem
to be sort of
because it is one of the decompositions
but you know like I said we're not happy
with the current just going to say we're
not happy with the current theorem once
so hopefully you know in the future
there will be a team with nicer
decompositions possibly at the cost of
adding more basic classes and certainly
comparability graphs are on the list
you know what we haven't actually tried
that I mean not obviously because right
there like I said there are two steps
which you reach which are hard and
there are algorithms to test if you're a
certain subclass and they're and they're
faster yeah but like if I tell you
here's a perfect graph and then in
addition it doesn't contain the cycle of
length 6 can you make it faster and then
I don't know
you could you could turn theorem one
into a polynomial time algorithm to get
the decomposition yes but that's not the
problem with it thank you very much